اعلن حزب الله اللبناني ان مقاتليه قصفوا
بالاسلحه الصاروخيه موقع رويسات الالم
الاسرائيلي في مزارع شبعه وتلال كفرشوبا
المحتله واضاف الحزب ان مقاتليه قصفوا
ايضا انتشارا للجنود الاسرائيليين في محيط
الموقع وحققوا اصابات مباشره وافاد مراسل
الجزيره ان صاروخين اطلقا من جنوب لبنان
باتجاه موقع اسرائيلي في اصبع
الجليل في المقابل اعلن الجيش الاسرائيلي
شن غاره جويه استهدفت ما وصفها بمجموعه
تخريبيه في منطقه عيترون بجنوب لبنان كما
اشار الى تنفيذ قارات جويه عده خلال
الساعه الساعات الاربعه وشرين الماضيه
استهدف ما قال انها بنى تحتيه ومبان
عسكريه في كل من الخيام وكفر قانه وجبل
البلاط واضاف الجيش الاسرائيلي ان قصفا
مدفعيا اسرائيليا استهدف مناطق الجبين وعي
الشعب وعيت رون في جنوب
لبنان معنا من الجليل الاعلى مراسل
الجزيره حسان سعود ليطلع على الروايه
الاسرائيليه ومن ابل السقي معنا جنوبيه من
جنوبيه لبنان مراسل الجزيره ايهاب العقدي
وابدا معك
ايهاب
ا هذا اليوم كان ايضا حاميا بالنسبه
للجبهه الجنوبيه على الرغم من تراجع
الاعمال القتاليه نسبيا مقارنه باليومين
او الاسبوع الماضي بسبب عوامل الطقس التي
كانت عاصفه ومطره في جنوب لبنان الطائرات
الحربيه الاسرائيليه نفذت عددا من الغارات
على بلده عيترون وعلى منطقه جبل بلاط في
زبقين وهي لا تبعد كثيرا عن تلك
المنطقه الطائرات الحربيه وبعدها [__] قامت
القوات الاسرائيليه بقصف مدفعي مركز على
بلده عيترون دمر منزل و تضرر عدد من
المنازل الاخرى في هذه البلده الحدوديه
التي تقع قباله مستوطن مطنه افيفيم
مستوطنه افيفيم استهدفها حزب الله
بصاروخ باتجاه احد المنازل التي يتحصن
فيها الجنود الاسرائيليون وقال انه حقق
اصابات وان العمليه كانت ردا على
الاستهدافات الاسرائيليه لمنازل المدنيين
اللبنانيين في جنوب لبنان ايضا حزب الله
كان خلال الايام السابقه قد وجه صواريخ
مشابهه باتجاه منازل في مستوطنات
اسرائيليه مختلفه مثل المناره والمطلي ردا
على الاستهدافات الاسرائيليه التي طاولت
منازل المدنيين في المناطق الحدوديه ما
لجنوب لبنان ايضا كان هناك قصف مدفعي
اسرائيلي على مناطق مختلفه من الجنوب في
منطقه القطاع الشرقي كان هناك قصف باتجاه
بلده الخيام محيط رشي الفخار وايضا
الفرديس وفرشو بلده كفرشوبا التي يقع على
تخومها عدد من المواقع الاسرائيليه استهدف
حزب الله مرتين احد المواقع وتجمعات
للجنود القريبه منه وهو الموقع المعروف
باسم رويسات العلم وقال انه حقق اصابات
ايضا المدفعيه الاسرائيليه كانت قصفت كذلك
بعض اطراف البلدات القريبه من محيط بلدات
مختلفه في القطاعين الاوسط والغربي وواصلت
المقاتلات الاسرائيليه حتى ساعه متاخره من
بعد ظهر هذا اليوم بالتحليق باستمرار في
اجواء لبنان بالاضافه الى المسيرات التي
واصلت تحليقها في بعض مناطق الجنوب نعم
وحسان الجانب الاسرائيلي تحدث ايضا عن
قيام اسرائيل بعده
غارات تماما الجانب الاسرائيلي تحدث عن
غارات استهدفت عيترون بشكل اساسي خلال
الساعات الماضيه فيما تحدث كذلك عن غارات
استهدف فت عده مناطق في جنوب لبنان خلال
الساعات ال 24 الماضيه من بينها مناطق كفر
قانا وجبل البلاط وكذلك الخيام بالاضافه
ايضا الى حديث الجيش الاسرائيلي عن
استهدافه بالقصف المدفعي لعده مناطق ايضا
في جنوب لبنان وكنا قد رصدنا خلال هذا
اليوم تكثيفا للضربات المدفعيه من الجانب
الاسرائيلي باتجاه جنوب لبنان وذلك بعدما
كانت سفرات الانذار قد دوت صباح اليوم في
ست بلدات مختلفه في المنطقه الشماليه
بالقرب من الحدود مع لبنان لاسما في كريات
شموني التي اعلنت بلديتها ان اربعه صواريخ
سقطت في مناطق قالت انها مناطق مفتوحه ولم
تؤدي الى اصابات او اضرار فيما الجيش
الاسرائيلي اعلن عن سقوط صاروخين فقط في
كريات شموني هذا اتى قبل ان يعلن وزير
الدفاع الاسرائيلي عن عده
تصريحات خلال كشف الجيش الاسرائيلي عن
زياره قام بها الى جبل الشيخ اليوم ولقائه
بالوحده الجبليه في الجيش الاسرائيلي خلال
هذه التصريحات هدد جالانت وزير الدفاع
الاسرائيلي حزب الله بانه لن يوقف الجانب
الاسرائيلي هجماته باتجاه لبنان ولن يوقف
اطلاق النار في حال
توقف توقفت الحرب وتوقف اطلاق النار في
غزه بشكل مباشر قال ان ظن حزب الله ان وقف
اطلاق النار في غزه سيعني وقفا لاطلاق
النار بشكل مباشر في الجبهه الشماليه فانه
سيكون مخطئا لان ذلك لن يتحقق الا اذا
تحقق الامن لسكان الشمال وعادوا الى قراهم
شكرا جزيلا لكما من الجليل الاعلى مراسل
الجزيره حسان مسعود كما اشكر ايضا ايهاب
العقده الذي كان معنا من ابلس السقي
جنوبيه لبنان